von doris teil ich habe den traum
gesehen ich sehe den traum den traum wie
ich bin einfach irgendwo rein gegangen
weil ich dachte dass ich hier nach clay
suchen könnte aber hier ist einfach
so freuen und herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren vorjahr
das wäre cool gewesen wenn ihr 10 herzen
schacht herzen schaden genommen das
herrlich krügel hilfen aber ich hab nur
zweieinhalb glaub ich bekommen herzlich
willkommen zurück zur capt auf minecraft
2 gestern kamen zwei videos das war
einfach weil bei mir falsch konvertiert
wurde dann habe ich dir einfach ein
bisschen vorgaben ist folge hochgeladen
haben wir alles super geplant tut uns
leid kommt nicht wieder vor
sie haben allerdings einen folge plaques
vollgepackten plan für diese folge und
zwar ist uns etwas aufgefallen komme du
also wir werden das erst mal aufteilen
die folge und zwar bitte unten nachdem
and raum suchen den wir endlich
langsamer haben sollten wir schon sehr
viele achievements geschafft haben und
zum langsam sollte mal freitags kommen
wird unten die ganze welt durch höhlen
und bei mir wird man sehen wie ich mich
daran versuche roten farbstoff zu
kriegen und die stern noch blumen und
alles mögliche ein paar sachen werde ich
versuchen hier
genaugenommen vollständigen plan
mal schauen wie das auch als es heute
schaffen in einer folge teure mieten
krassen vor allem ich muss auch noch im
netz gehen und netter warzen holen fürs
verzaubern für den sternen da gehe ich
auch mal rein um zu schauen ob da
eventuell mittlerweile meingast es
manche mit manchmal funktioniert
wirklich nicht mit dem marsch uns wie
was also wir hatten heute habe ich
nämlich auch in den kommentaren gelesen
und zwar dergestalt sogar in minecraft
vor um das es geht moment erst mal
klären worum es geht
aber das asian gezeigt und zwar immer
halten roten pilz den ofen park dann
sollte normalerweise so rote farbe
rauskommen aber anscheinend klappt es
nicht obwohl es in die kommentare
geschrieben worden
das stand auch drin es gibt drei
diamanten aber aber trotzdem warum geht
das nicht überall steht es geht und ja
keine ahnung
ja ich werde da nicht also was wir
eigentlich gedacht hätten wäre wenn man
irgendwie die maschen brennen sollte das
steht sogar minecraft form und das geht
einfach nicht dass es ein bisschen
traurig das geht nicht
ich brauch heart and play alter daran
hapert es gerade wir brauchen mehr clay
wenn du irgendwo clay siehst oder so
braucht es in der höhle hier ist kennt
sich ja gar kein klient ul war nicht in
der ersten war da nicht auch irgendwo
klemmt oder das gras stewart weiß ja
noch ein gast grings was auch wichtig
nicht ab wenn wir
wir hoffen also wirklich dreht man
dazwischen wenn wir leder brauchen
sollen wir die mit dem plünderung
clownfisch von uns schlagen weil dann
kann sein dass wir mehr lehrer bekommen
dass sein bruder tobias jetzt einfach
mal die party erst mal ganz kurz damit
wir hier nicht die kompletten kühe töten
sollen sich wieder muss die bbq erste
baby co da unten so jetzt hörte ich
diese kuh mit dem clown fisch das dauert
jetzt eventuell ein bisschen aber man
soll damit angeblich fiel bis zu vier
räder bekommen und ich habe jetzt drei
räder bekommen von einer kuh das schon
mal ganz gut da brauchen wir viel glück
ach so ja komm ich denke also nee ich
glaube nicht dass ich habe drei leute
sind hier zwei gas 2022 sind hier aber
wir brauchen harten clay wir brauchen
einfach clay
das ist so wichtig das kann man nie
sagen wir den clay light gray hier kommt
die null anfangen müsse warte warte ich
jetzt dass man also wir brauchen echt
clay um dieses mit diesem magenta das zu
machen was ich vorhatte
ja ich mag die andere sachen auch erst
mal hier rein mit dem wir verzaubern
können et cetera aus dem leder können
wir eventuell acht das sogar kommen zwar
wieder anschauen um ist es eigentlich
wieder gewachsen hast du schon mal
verkauft hat mich nachgeguckt wo welche
abgeschossen nein
jetzt habe ich die falsche angegriffen
yahoos gewachsen als die falsche
gegriffen ist gewachsen was wie baum hat
er nicht getroffen
ich hab doch genau auf den gast auch
treffen prozent die gast auf jeden fall
auf mich aufmerksam gewordener gut ich
bin auch gleich tot dass es nicht ganz
zu teilen
ich habe 31 zucker ruhig mal ist man
noch ein paar büchlein das ist doch das
ist doch kein sterben gar nicht dadurch
warum stellen die nicht schon wieder ein
bücherregal das läuft echt gut
ja was ist eigentlich sterben und ich
bin gleich tot wenn ich so weitermache
wie gerade die den gas bis zum rad dabei
das mit dem gas zu machen ja aber er hat
mit eigenen waffen
das ding ist ich habe hier pixies
angegriffen und ich bin gleich tot wenn
ich mich jetzt nicht sofort aus hölle
er kommt raus und zwei herzen kommendes
ich bin traurig wort nicht betroffen
mit einem halbherzig habe die rüstung ja
sogar an die wollte ich nicht verlieren
alter falter die hält er gar nichts aus
warten wir können jetzt schon bis ich
packe man schwer teilen ist das sollten
wir ihn geht jetzt schon ich versuch's
mal ganz kurz mit diamant schwert oder
was brauchen wir brauchen stecke zwei
glaube ich sogar als trank auf jeden
fall ja damit alter wir brauchen noch
mehr leser also hölle ist mir das war
schon wieder zu herzlich ich gehe mal
runter denn die in die höhlenwelt
vielleicht finde ich da ja irgendwie in
erste mal nach dem n traum am besten
genau zehn jahren noch lange nicht
gefunden und h den claim brauchen wir
auf jeden fall
ich habe fünf stück ich brauch noch drei
stücke dann können wir das nutzen
magenta machen ich komme einfach mal das
machst du dich wohl grad nach vorn was
machst du eigentlich da oben ja ich
suche ich suche die was ich versuche
weiter zu kommen die suche die ganze
zeit nach irgendwelchen lose danach in
sachen die wir machen können und man wir
brauchen auf jeden fall dings baden clay
das wäre so dicht aber aktiv mit dran
ich kann mal eben meine theorie den
zuschauern erklären ich kann mir gut
vorstellen wie war ja damals die coolen
die hölle gegangen ist damals sind wir
auch auf der falschen seite rausgekommen
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
irgendwie dabei jetzt die hölle verpackt
ist dadurch und wir damals die gas dreht
sich mehr angreifbar sind weil die als
eigentlich mehr erkannt werden von
captain keiner ahnt die guards meinst du
ja ja das war echt scheiße wenn wir das
richtig machen können ich suche auch
schon die ganze zeit nach clay hier
überall hier ist einfach nichts jetzt
holz aber deshalb freue ich nehm das
holz zuletzt mit ich weiß wo wir am
anfang die gänge geschlendert wenn nur
zwei folgen wieder aufgefallen ist hier
ist er überall holz in den chefs in den
main chefs und so was alles als krasse
sache wir brauchen echte und claims
gleis geleitet
ja ich habe gerade das gleiche hindernis
sie bei mir
da sind recht zu mit das wichtigste was
wir benötigen also wenn du da welchen
ziehst directly mitnehmen ich komm mach
es tobias terhardt clay brauchst du
gerade seiten ging oder wo bist du ich
bin gerade in dieser monster brüne weißt
du da wo wir 1000 seglern namen so ein
bisschen musste richtig aufpassen die
sind schon wieder 1000 kripomann lg noch
mehr als 1000 euro ich bin ich bin ich
bin bei diesem gang wo wir uns mal
verlaufen haben und ich bin mal
verließen waren wo ist hier unten ich
noch irgendwo eine kiste eventuell
freigesetzt worden durch die ganze nicht
geschafft haben hier ist einfach noch an
stoner wo das betone ich brauche einfach
alles bonner ab er macht das außer
skeletts bonner die konnte man noch
gebrauchen eventuell für knochen- oder
weg wo ja nee is klar ist brauchen
beiden hülle bekommt man dadurch besser
skelett und sie bringen viele level hier
in der normalen welt bau die ruhig ab ja
mach ich auch aber ich verstehe es nicht
wir brauchen euch oder ist eine kiste in
einem archiv mit komm wieder eine kiste
und nehme stetig gesehen eine spitzhacke
ist bald wieder kaputt ich muss wieder
nach oben eine schiefe alter immer nur
ein verdammt schief meint was könnte die
halle dann gehe ich in die hölle wenn
das so ist ja jung ist auf jeden fall
eine kiste die nach einem schiff mit
kommt das war ganz cool wenn wir die
noch kriegen könnten irgendwie aber ich
gehe jetzt glaube ich auch erst mal den
weg hier weiter runter wieder auf alte
häuser irgendwo hier muss doch klar sein
wir können nicht unsere ganzen clay
fahrrad namen doch es hapert gerade an
den play und nicht an den nicht an den
farbstoffen so wie damals immer das kann
man nie sein hier unten muss doch
irgendwo noch klar sein das ist das gold
überall europas aufkommt ich gehe wie
ausländer raus so ganz meine schicht
übernehmen schrieb am wasser machte kein
schaden
oh gott ich hasse das wenn ich schon
skelett sehr alter hast du eine
spitzhacke dabei wenn man wenn du dich
einbauen muss und dann keine mehr hast
ich habe eine mit der ok wir dann viel
für den end raum
nee also müssen wir auch mal langsam
finden das war wieder hoch ich war ja
gerade auf der suche aber ohne
spitzhacke auch kein end raum bestimmt
wenn du keine hast ein bisschen tor mit
der hand durch einfach soll ich gucke
jetzt hier einfach nach ok hier ist gar
nix das kann doch nicht sein hier muss
doch irgendwo oder ich grad mal ganz
kurz einfach hingegangen seite muss doch
irgendwo clay seien jetzt eisen in dem
eisen mit eisen brauchen wir auch alte
alter ich hab nur ich hab ich komm ich
habe nicht an ohne spaß habe ich kann
ihnen vor eingebaut ich habe sonst
allerdings gehört so ein tolles teil
ich habe den traum gesehen ich sehe den
traum den traum wie ich bin einfach
irgendwo rein gegangen weil ich dachte
dass ich hier nach clay suchen könnte
aber ich jetzt einfach die rentrop komm
mal runter kommen runter nun also erst
eine spitzhacke ich bin so ein bisschen
ekelhaft an den rhein gebohrt jetzt
nicht den and roam gefunden aber ich
glaube erst noch die hälfte davon
abhängt moment nicht was deine aufgabe
wart ihr kommt jetzt bestimmt sein
catalin woraus hey hast du den anlauf
nach unten da hier sind diese ekligen
silberfische du hast nicht den eindruck
doch hier sind hier sind hier den diese
ganzen selber fische doch hier ist ein
traum aber es ist nur helfende
freigesetzt und die hälfte freiheit
währte bald da fischer um mein gott oh
mein gott
aber man konnte total mehr anbrennen
dann kommst du daran dann die an die
also könnte es wieder rein springen wenn
das irgendwie frei wäre ein traum als
setzt ja genau kommst du dich bei uns
einen weg hin damit wir da nicht
irgendwie noch an die lava fallen alter
gras der ich jedoch mein die hölle
ich hoffe jetzt dass hier nicht irgendwo
dann otto geßler man die hände ja okay
wenn du willst kannst mir ja gast
mitbringen
ein wasserrad sind wer ganz hilfreich
ja ich glaube dass sie nicht
als kommt jetzt auch schon hier von der
seite an
wir sind aber nicht so viele wie bei
captain minecraft 1 cent ja weil wir
endlich auch gerade ganz gut unter
kontrolle hat und wie er mittlerweile
auch ein bisschen rüstung am start haben
auch zombies elftplatzierten an ganz
fremde katzen
am schönsten wäre es einfach wenn ich
jetzt noch irgendwie so ein dings kommen
würde etwas sondern clay vorkommen nicht
wundervoll ja immer weiter in die höhe
nach ganz unten da wurde auch die
diamanten gefunden haben da könnte man
ja noch welche finden weil clay meine
ich jetzt also wenn jemand aber clay
eventuell findest du da unten noch was
ja ich kann mich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz noch rein
in diesem end raum ich schaue mal ganz
kurz wie man das alles hier
ob wir da schon rein können ich weiß
nicht wir haben ja obenende perlen
locker ein paar gottes kommen ja auch
noch silber tisch an ich werde mir
direkt angegriffen
da kommt was er tut mir echt leid
mitzubringen ist wäre hier wirklich wir
fast tot
nur durch die ganzen gas die
herumschwirren
und ich habe so viel koppel stars
einfach mit kumpels zu nehmen ich bin
gleich wer tot ist dann noch in der lava
freunde seit ich hoffe mal ihr seid
damit zufrieden was ich hier mache mein
gott jetzt kommt er schon wieder selber
vier oben ist alles zerstört wo ich
gerade langlauf alles kaputt ziel hier
noch einen hin
so jetzt aber ganz komplett zu nicht
getroffen
oh gott nein ich kann den selber für
sportler gar nicht abbauen
vom treff ich bin ja ja ist krass ich
habe waren auf der suche nach clay
jetzt kommt sie schon wieder welche
weiter geht doch weg schon wieder hätte
schaden genommen
mein gott mein herz ich werde das
sterben glaube ich am feuersee ich lebe
noch bedingungen wir morgen 1 2345 ender
perlen die wir da reinpacken der region
gefühl kommen wir oben ein paar weiß
nicht ob er das in der nächsten folge
einfach machen dann dann komme ich jetzt
wieder nach oben und dann können wir ich
bin in der hölle und ich das ist echt
saukomisch mit den gast also ich
normalerweise hätte ich die schlange
treffen müssen und was geht hier ab das
problem ist ich werde da nicht das
problem ist vielmehr gerade ich werde
von den big zombies gejagt weil ich dir
einmal aus versehen geschlagen habe er
hoffentlich merken wir uns dass mit dem
portal da oben er da unten ist es
irgendwie verlieren oder so ich war noch
nie da aber das verhältnis war echt
krass direkt aber wir so eine kleine
höhle ich schon hatten war das und wir
denken uns auch immer so jo
wir finden das nie das muss er ihm unter
der map sein aber dann haben es einfach
gefunden alter das echt krass oh mein
gott ich bin gut überlebt das bild bei
leben wird es ich schwimme jetzt auch
noch ganz schnell nach oben also das mit
dem place echt ärgerlich dass mit dem
clay wie können wir denn sonst noch clay
kriegen
ich verstehe dass carl aus der höhle
irgendwo wird ihr wohl noch klar sein wo
ich hoffe es ich hoffe dass ich haftet
sonst klar die leiter weiter hoch ich
hab mich wieder in die hölle gehe ich
nicht mit der folge heute aber ich
glaube ich komme auch nicht mehr lebend
heraus solle verbindlich jedes ich bin
ich bin selber auch in einer minute bin
ich bei uns wieder oben drin
ja ich bin ich total bist du warst du
dabei auch nur der komplette die rüstung
etwas wichtiges mit oder sich die
rüstung die brauchen wir es ende gehen
wir rein ich hole mir die eben wieder
ist er kein ding weil eben da rein
du hattest wirklichen die rüstung an
auch junge wie kannst du dir dann
sterben fifa.com mal in die hölle kommt
nun bald das ist die hölle hölle so aber
alles wieder okay dann kommt zurück ja
keine ahnung leute wie kommen wir an
play ist jetzt halte diese frage der
fragen die ganz normale frauen
was sollte ich denn jetzt noch machen
wenn ich tot bin ach so ich wollte
schauen wir ob wir das mit den händlern
noch hinkriegen
jetzt warten schon mal zwei ender perlen
ich weiß es nicht ich hänge jetzt hier
im portal auch noch zwei das auch noch
zu oft schon sechs stück hast du places
was ich kann gar nicht gucken portal
fest hast du places getötet wir brauchen
noch auf 4players.de komme nicht raus
ich komm mir nicht rausholen kleiner
dieser [ __ ] claim böses wort darf
nicht geschafft ist da erleben
ich bin wieder lebend hier ja sehr gut
haben wir noch feilen hier auch eine
feile alter ich habe auch keinen place
mitgebracht auch komme das ist das die
hölle los
ja du bist wird das nein ohne wird so
viel los ich gehe nicht mehr die hölle
gut ich gleich eine hölle wollt ihr ihn
wie viel chaos wirklich jetzt allerdings
seht ihr das in der nächsten folge bei
komme auf dem kanal weil diese folge
neigt sich dem ende zu und daten würde
ich sagen es euch gefallen hat würde ich
mich sehr gut über einen daumen hoch
vollen nächste folge morgen bei komme
hoffentlich wieder pünktlich und dann
sehen uns